remember that guy that jumped over the
counter and in the this at the smoke
shop in Vegas and the Asian dude just
goes that's a r that one of those come
on man don't do that he jumped
over I love that and I was like what the
[__] I love
[Music]
that two men who are convicted of felony
theft for stealing more than $2,000
worth of merchandise from a Kohl's store
from Kohl's that's a lot of [__]
that's a lot of quantity probably went
electon Co has great deals they are
arguing that they should have their
felony charges bumped down to a
misdemeanor because the the items were
on sale and they had coupons really so
they were trying to get rid of them
anyway so it brings the value lower
coupons are valid during theft that is
an amazing well they're arguing that it
wasn't $2,000 worth so it should be
knocked down to a misdemeanor because it
has all his coupons didn't they change
the definition of grand theft though
recently that's why people can steal 950
all the [__] yeah right in California I
think this is well California you
there's no theft you just grab whatever
you
want self checkout
everywhere self checkout you know when I
see all those uh videos now of people
like just rushing it looks like those
like TV shows when they had the shopping
spree game shows where it's like sweep
yeah and then you run in with your
[__] cart and you just are piling it
up and you just run out and I'm all like
that's why the kids are so good at it
they know the strategy it's [__]
insane I feel so bad for the workers cuz
the workers are just
like dude D watching a bunch of
middle-aged women throw a bunch of
turkeys into a shopping carart is
[__] hilarious dude
turkeys you got to go high value first
and they're just going like that like
that with the turkeys it's the best dude
that is a really funny argument though
right it is true because you always
wonder how they come up with those
totals you know is that the sale price
or is that the full retail cuz what if
what if someone goes on top of that and
says all right I want the manufacturing
price the wholesale price like they
can't do the retail price these guys are
digging deep trying to get out of this
felony [__] so they're like you know we
got all there's there so all this stuff
was if you look up the coupons it's all
less than they're saying so they had a
pocket full of coupons hey so so so if
you had if that was your lawyer would
you be like oh yo that's a that's a
tight move thank you for even thinking
like is that is that considered a good
lawyer you know and by the way on top of
the coupons you're student so you get
student discount oh [__] you're military
military discount veteran
discount oh it adds up those Val those
savings do add up dude but what do you
want from Kohl's though what do you guys
get from Kohl's [__] dude these guys
were taking kitchen A
Appliances see Supermarket sweeps valet
sweep yeah you go for the electronics
and yeah kitchen is expensive and get
this I'm not making this up these guys
were called The Kitchen Aid mixer crew
like like wet Bandits but these guys are
the kitchena mixer crew yeah well they
went strictly for the appliances going
highend [__] yeah mostly kitchen app is
that made up is that a Steve Green
[__] improv I swear it's not look
kitchen a mix crew is it the reviews are
in and it's
hot best [__] is sitting next to a
dancer he doesn't know I have notepad
open it's nothing it say nothing on
there but the the sand mixers bro you
get you get to mix all the different
attachments those are expensive that
[__] adds what what was the actual total
over over 2,000 $294 I respect anybody
who's able to even come up with
something new to say in this situation
cuz you think you've heard it all with
at least they're trying Hey this is
Colorado yeah I heard Colorado is kind
of like California where it's very like
like wokey theft theft under $2,000 is a
misdemeanor offense under
2,000 but we just let people go though
so that's why they're trying to get it
knocked down cuz it's $294 so like some
of this [__] was on sale dude yeah hey
you what if what if they're like you
plus taxed yeah exactly tax is already
theft so dude they're really trying to
like stretch the system how do they
total that up it is interesting cuz if
you think about like let's say you you
went to Pet Boys and you stole four
tires the the fourth one's free usually
yeah see so like are they putting that
into the [__] consideration well Pro
prosecutors are basically saying sales
and discounts are only for paying
customers who can't use that [__] that's
a very straightforward sensible answer I
I get it yeah so that lawyer does is not
that good then we'll see it's only for
paying customers yeah I that's fair is
it so one of the guys got sentenced to
15 months in prison and then another the
other guy got sentenced 90 days in jail
why for stealing Where Have You Been
video no but why does this guy get less
than the other guy no why does one guy
get 15 years and why does one guy get 90
days Well's the getaway driver I don't
know the other guy the other guy who
carried more stuff during Supermarket
Sweep he was putting the turkeys in
totals dude one guy was the Anthony Lee
and one guy was the Ry anim Anthony
Lee's like hey you go steal this and Ry
anim is like all right he's the guy
doing all the work ideas guy yeah the
ideas guy the guy that you need the guy
that's most important but then what
happens if you steal things from like
let's say like a vintage market that's
Outdoors like are they going to go by
the tags nah like how do you find the
the value of things no one's they're
going to let them go they're they're
going to think twice about that they're
going to be like those guys on eBay who
are like you know that they sell they
resell [__] like look for the last sale
right right the last High cuz like what
if you [__] up and you actually stole
like a mly crew real vintage shirt oh
yeah you're 5,000 in the hole now oh
you're done though like that's crazy
you're going to jail baby it just seems
weird like how do they tally these
things up when they're not actual like
barcode Goods did you guys hear about
the the uh Smash and grabs at the Sanita
Mall recently yeah I couldn't believe it
happened there yeah what happened so
it's it's a store that my wife loves to
go into and they have like they have a
rebag and it's they called rebag yeah so
it's like all the nice vintage Chanel
designer bags and then people send them
sell them secondhand oh cool so but each
bag is like [__]
1,500 like they're they're a gang of
money but like there's a security guard
in there they have to buzz you in with
the with the glass doors and then you
can go in and there's only like two
people at a time apparently they went in
there smashed it with a sledgehammer oh
they smashed that place apparently they
smashed it grabbed everything [__]
dipped out W it said to see it happen at
at a mall that nice yeah but I'm
surprised it doesn't happen more though
honestly dude Tiff's Pur is like 15 H
each Jesus bro she likes to collect them
she's like they're what they she's like
it's an asset I'm like I don't know cuz
it's vintage true those do have a really
high for sure for sure if she knows her
[__] yeah she she she likes the pieces
but like they're [__] I'm like dude
that much for a purse a lot of people
are getting smart going like oh [__] you
know who we haven't touched the Asian
neighborhoods cuz they have hell of
money yeah what damn well there's rap
songs that talk about that did you hear
that there's there's rap there's like
like a rap song I forgot who I me I
think it was anal Chopper somebody had a
rap the lyric that said something like
hit the Asian houses cuz they don't
believe in Banks oh T did they shout out
the sgv sh thank
you dud what if you're a robber and you
go into an Asian house and then you're
like [__] where's the money that's not
here and and you're like damn I learned
something about stereotypes today yeah
sometimes they're not always
true wow what a wow what a powerful
moment can't judge everything by wow
some stereotypes are not true wow as the
camera zooms out and they stay
themselves in the
mirror dang yeah these Smash and grabs
are SM there was a smash and grab at
Stonewood mall like not too long ago
which mall Stonewood in Downey oh it's
like where my my parents go and my mom
my mom's so cute she like was showing me
the video and she's like that's where
your dad bought the engagement ring for
me like in the'80s wow I felt so bad she
was like so sad looking at the footage
of them just ransacking it
it's so sad you think about like how
hard your your dad was working to like
afford that like ring and then some dude
just like I wonder when it's going to
turn around when they're actually going
to arrest these [__] I don't
know there was a a methhead yesterday
that came to the store and um at the the
the June be in Hawaii dude that video is
crazy and then they uh just grabbed the
tip jar oh when one of my uh employees
was just turned around making a drink he
just grabbed the CH tip jar and walked
away Dam and then he looks like a grown
ass dude like and it's like you just
stole from a buch of kids dude you're a
[__] idiot and the thing is the tip
Char usually just has like 20 bucks in
there so it's like you did all of that
and it goes a long way for the kids yeah
but he wanted the coins though for the
laundry and stuff probably he need he
needed coins no he couldn't get change
anywhere be a little empathetic okay
he's got a free laundry for the next 6
months who's really who's really dumb
yeah dude I mean he didn't look like a
homeless guy like he looked like a Able
Body dude that can get a [__] job who
washes his clothes at that prob life
dude the one time I encountered theft
like they're actually super like uh not
smart I I guess smart I guess cool it
was
cool charismatic they're very like
crafty in the way they're like actually
like thinking about what's the most
expensive item cuz I I did a retail at a
convention and it's busy and we usually
have our clothes out on these racks and
there's this one expensive jacket where
I'm just standing there watching it but
as we change shifts that's when they
would go oh so they monitor you they're
walking around looking at you and then
they time it like very precisely as soon
as you switch they they grab it yeah
there was another theft that happened at
my store too where this guy was kind of
waiting for the employees to go to the
front cuz we have a back kitchen area
and then I guess one of the employees
just walked in and didn't lock the door
cuz they were bringing some stuff from
you know the storage and then right when
they moved we saw this in the camera he
opened opened it up stuck his hand down
in this like little area they had bags
and stuff grabbed some headphones like
some beat spot Dre and then he he walked
out I'm like damn that's crazy like he
he specifically took headphones nothing
else smart dude see that's what I'm
saying like they're they're smart enough
to know the timing of what to steal what
to take yeah cuz if he took a purse a
wallet or whatever people would have
like been what the [__] right but I
guess no one really noticed throughout
the day and they're like oh where's my
headphones and they're like oh I
yeah but the thing is it's like if you
get caught though it's like yeah that'd
be so I was thinking how funny it would
be if they had bait stores that are not
even real stores but they're just meant
for people to smash and grab and then it
just shuts the door dud that would be so
nice like a like a humanid rat trap
that' be so amazing what isn't that
entament why is that even aw wrongful
imprisonment I don't like that yo you
know one of my favorite videos is
remember that guy that jumped over the
counter and in the this at the smoke
shop in Vegas and the Asian dude just
goes
that's a rough bro that would be one of
those come on man don't do that he
jumped
over I love that and I was like what the
[__] I love that fck I love that [__]
have the Vegas boys been in uh any uh
Targets in California recently no no so
we got this really dope feature in
California that they don't have in Vegas
where if you want to get maybe a stick
of deodorant you have to press a buzzer
cuz it's all locked up so it's extra
safe for all of us the Vegas people
don't have it cuz you guys are [__]
bums you guys will never get this and
you have to press the button and then an
employee comes maybe 5 minutes maybe
like 5 seconds and they'll come around
and then they'll unlock the thing for
you and then give you your stick of
deodorant just to give it to you did
they escort you after that you just
pocket it after
that I never thought of that actually
but it's [__] annoying so uh last
month I didn't go to a Target but I did
go to like a r Aid Gio I think left her
makeup bag at home so she like oh [__] I
need some makeup we go to Ride Aid and
every single thing is locked so she's
like okay mascara they have to come and
unlock it and then uh okay lipstick okay
that has to be unlocked and then [__]
Foundation whatever that has to be
unlocked like every single personal
shopper it's cool what that it's a
personal shopper it helps you uh like a
coner yeah I'm surprised they don't have
this in Vegas that's a good way of
looking at what blew my mind is like big
ass stores like Whole Foods and Target
left certain places that's that's the
big that's the biggest I'm just like I
didn't think those businesses would ever
like leave a city me either but did you
see what happened at the Watts Nike shop
what because the you know the Nike
there's a Nike store in Watts it's like
a really like uh vulnerable area but uh
it doesn't normally get robbed because
the actual neighborhood takes care of it
like they don't want to rob their own
joint so like the day that it did get
robbed and a bunch of people did a smash
and grab there the neighborhood stood in
front of it wow that's dope dude see
that's [__] tight because they were
like we don't want Nike to leave like
cuz that's going to there's people that
have jobs there but that's the way you
do it man like your own hood takes care
of the the stuff there that was so sick
we need to do that at Sanita mall or
were they blocking it there's not enough
people to block them all dude dude all
those
entrances takes 1,600 people what if
they were just blocking it cuz like no
I'm going to go steal that [__] tomorrow
you better not take the inventory today
yeah yeah they're camping
out they're camping out to steal it it's
dope cuz it it really looks like a bunch
of people loitering in the parking lot
all night but they were really
protecting it
some dope stuff what they need to do at
the Santa mall is create a Great
Wall Gang is Con Great Wall that's a
good idea they start lighting the fires
D across it's a landmark and it serves a
[Music]
purpose